♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP VOTED TO DEFEND THE
POLICE LAST YEAR.
WHAT DID THEY DO WITH ALL THE
MONEY?
THEY PUT SOME OF IT INTO A NEW
INITIATIVE TO DEGRADE AND
DESTROY THEIR OWN PEOPLE.
THE CITY IS NOW RUNNING THE
HOMELESS SHELTER THAT IS PASSING
OUT HEROIN PIPES AND
DISTRIBUTING SO-CALLED BOOTY
PUMP IT KIDS AND FOR REAL.
THE HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT
SAY THE PROGRAM REFLECTS THE
VARIED NEEDS OF THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
SEATTLE.
JASON RANTZ EIGHT RADIO HOST
DOCUMENTING THE DESTRUCTION OF
HIS CITY JOINS US TONIGHT.
JASON THANK YOU FOR COMING ON
AND IF YOU REALLY HATED THE
PEOPLE YOU WERE IN CHARGE OF, IT
SEEMS YOU WOULD DO THINGS LIKE
THIS.
>> WHEN YOU TEACH ADDICTS WHO
ARE ALREADY THE HARDEST TO GET
OFF OF THE STREETS A MORE
EFFICIENT WAY TO GET HIGH AND A
WAY THAT LAST LONGER WHEN YOU
ARE DOING THE SO-CALLED BOOTY
BUMP KIDS.
YOU MAKE IT THAT MUCH EASIER TO
STAY ADDICTED TO.
WE ARE AN ORGANIZATION OF
DOWNTOWN EMERGENCY SERVICES
CENTER THAT SHOULD BE HELPING
THESE PEOPLE.
THEY SAY THIS IS ALL PART OF A
HOME PRODUCTION MODEL THAT IS
ABOUT BEING WHERE THE ADDICT IS
MAKING SURE THAT SINCE THEY WERE
GOING TO ENGAGE IN THIS BEHAVIOR
ANYWAY, AT LEAST THEY ARE DOING
IT SAFER.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE
RESULTS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES AND
HOPELESSNESS AND ADDICTION IS
GETTING WORSE IN SEATTLE AND
KING  COUNTY.
TO BE JUST HAD A STUNNING
INCREASE.
AND THAT IS IN THE LANGUAGE OF
THE VERY PEOPLE DOING THE STUDY
OF AN INCREASE IN SENTIMENTAL
OVERDOSES, GOING THROUGH THE
ROOF.
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY, WE ARE
SEEING THE RESULTS WORSENING,
NOT GETTING BETTER.
SO MAYBE REDUCTION IS LITERALLY
DOING THE OPPOSITE.
>> Tucker: MAYBE IT IS
INTENTIONAL.
IF YOU DID THIS TO YOUR KIDS
COME OBVIOUSLY YOU WOULD HATE
YOUR KIDS AND MAKE IT EASY FOR
THEM TO DO HEROIN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE -- IT WILL KILL
THEM ULTIMATELY.
WHY ISN’T IT VERY CLEAR TO US
THAT THEY WOULDN’T DO THIS TO A
POPULATION THEY LOVED OR CARED
ABOUT?
>> BECAUSE HE HAS SORT OF BEEN
TO THIS PC CULTURE.
THEY WOULD SAY THEY DON’T WANT
TO STIGMATIZE ANYBODY
EXPERIENCING THIS.
YOU AND I HAVE HAD THIS POSITION
BEFORE.
I DON’T WANT TO STIGMATIZE
PEOPLE BUT PEOPLE THAT ARE SICK
AND NEED HELP BUT THE ACT OF
SHOOTING UP OR SMOKING HEROIN.
YOU SHOULD NOT BE GLORIFYING IT.
WE SHOULD NOT BE MAKING IT SOUND
LIKE IT IS EXCITING TO GIVE
ANOTHER ASPECT OF DRUG ADDICTION
A TRY.
WE SHOULD BE MAKING SURE
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE.
IT IS NOT OKAY TO DO THIS IN A
PARK.
IT IS NOT OKAY TO DO THIS IN AN
ALLEYWAY, AND IT IS NOT OKAY TO
DO IT IN A CITY BACKED CENTER
FOR HOMELESS, ESPECIALLY NOT
OKAY TO DO IT WITH CITY
FUNDS.
>> Tucker: THE FUNNY THING IS
IF THEY WERE PASSING OUT
MARLBOROS TO PEOPLE THEY WOULD
FREAK OUT.
THOSE ARE BAD FOR YOU.